son accident de vélo et du fait
que le casque à sauver sa vie.
- J'ai une paupière qui ouvre
pas, ça fait que je vois juste
avec un oeil. Ça fait que
j'ai perdu tout le 3D.
- Adepte du vélo de montagne,
Alexandre Thivierge
a vu sa vie basculer
le 19 novembre 2015.
Il avait 18 ans.
ALEXANDRE THIVIERGE, ambassadeur
Jamais sans mon casque
- Je me disais : "Ah, je vais
pas porter mon casque, il va
rien m'arriver." J'ai glissé
sur le pont parce qu'il y avait
un petit peu d'eau puis
j'ai fait un face à face
avec l'arbre.
- Deux mois dans le coma, un an
de réadaptation et six ans plus
tard, il sait que ça vue ne
reviendra jamais comme avant.
C'est pour éviter aux plus
jeunes de commettre la même
erreur qu'il participe à
la tournée "Jamais sans mon
casque", en partageant
sa mésaventure.
- Un doigt en dessous ici.
- La tournée roule sa bosse
depuis plusieurs années. Simon
Poulin et son équipe ont déjà
remis plus de 6000 casques
à des jeunes provenant
majoritairement de familles
à faible revenu.
41 % des adolescents qui ont
fait une chute à vélo ne
portaient pas de casque, selon
des statistiques colligées
de 2016 à 2019. Cette proportion
augmente à 61 % pour
les accidents en planche
à roulettes.
- On pourrait parler
de pourcentage puis
de statistiques. Le problème,
c'est qu'on a encore des groupes
d'individus qui persistent
à ne pas le porter et qui ont
une influence puis un ascendant
sur les générations à venir.
GENEVIÈVE GUILBAULT, ambass.,
Jamais sans mon casque
- Nous, on a un devoir aussi
d'exemplarité. Donc, nous,
les parents, quand on fait
du vélo, quand on fait des
activités, on devrait toujours
aussi porter un casque pour
montrer l'exemple à nos enfants.
- Prêcher par l'exemple,
c'est la stratégie que prône
Jamais sans mon casque.
ÈVE-MARIE TANGUAY
- Nos jeunes, des fois, c'est
pas concret quand on leur en
parle à la maison. Mais quand
il voit des cas, qu'il voit
des cas vécus, c'est là,
je pense, qu'ils prennent plus
conscience, exactement,
de l'ampleur que ça peut avoir
de ne pas écouter les consignes
concernant le casque ou plein
d'autres choses aussi de la vie.
- Le message d'Alexandre fait
son chemin auprès de ceux qui
l'entendent.
JAYKE NADEAU
- Bien, ça peut nous aider pour
qu'on l'oublie jamais, de mettre
notre casque, parce que c'est
dangereux si on en met pas.
ÉMILE VENABLE